we've got snow that's piling up in the
mountains and we've got some very strong
Gusty winds also some thunderstorms that
have produced some hail in the southwest
Valley in the spring Spring Valley area
but look at the Palm Tree on top of the
Red Rock Casino Resort it is really
bending in the wind temperatures in the
50s starting to actually cool off just a
couple of degrees because of the rain
showers that have been moving in now in
the last 30 minutes 47 Indian Springs 53
in Mesquite 50 in Pahrump lots of areas
are getting 20 30 40 plus mile an hour
winds and we're certainly feeling those
chillier 30s for Reno and Tonopah let's
check some of these wind gusts just in
the last 15 minutes now Red Rock has had
a 54 mile an hour wind gust Kyle Canyon
the mid-levels 49 mile per hour wind
gusts Angel Peak though up above 7000
feet has seen 60 plus mile an hour winds
North Henderson 40 plus in North Las
Vegas near 40 mile an hour winds the
wind advisory took effect at 10 am and
those winds were on a dime came up out
of the South now and have been
increasing we're already starting to see
the showers turning into thunderstorms
producing Vivid lightning strikes now
across the southern end of the Spring
Mountain range and moving right across
I-15 and into the valley winter storm
warnings are still in place for the
mountains these thunderstorms are likely
to produce thunder snow and that's kind
of an explosion of the snow out of the
clouds and then maybe some brief
isolated heavy downpours in the lower
elevations but wherever you see these
marks those are lightning strikes a
really unstable upper level atmosphere
and that's what's causing the
thunderstorms with the possible hail and
again Southwest Valley we've already
seen a little hail and some heavier rain
right in the middle of town so the
chance for thunderstorms stays with us
for the rest of the afternoon now we're
going to have some updated rain totals
here within the next half hour but so
far we've seen almost a quarter of an
inch of rain at Red Rock two tenths of
an inch just about up in the Northwest
Valley Town Center in Summerlin Parkway
over a tenth of an inch many
neighborhoods since early this morning
haven't really added to anything more
than about four hundredths of an inch
but now that we've got more rain in the
center of town those rain totals will
start adding up wind advisory for all
lower elevations in place now and those
will continue until six o'clock tonight
winter storm warnings also include the
strong Gusty winds along with the heavy
snowfall and those are in place until
tomorrow afternoon we've already made it
to 59 degrees if we get the winds with a
little more sun we could make it to
about 60 but we're looking at showers
through the afternoon with possible
thunderstorms continuing hail lightning
in these very strong winds this will
last until about the evening hours and
then there's a possibility of some wrap
around showers early in the morning
mainly for Eastern Clark County tomorrow
partly cloudy much cooler as we get
through the rest of the week and there
is a chance of some showers on Thursday
again with another system